.
Ich musste nicht viel aufgeben.
Man entscheidet sich für einen Weg.
Er hat sein Leben aufgegeben,
um hierherzukommen.
Was ich ihm sagen möchte, kommt oft
auf Englisch nicht so raus,
wie es auf Schweizerdeutsch wäre.
Ich habe mir keine Ziele gesetzt
für die Zukunft,
weder in der Schweiz
noch in China.
Es läuft einfach.
Es gibt Frauen,
die würden ihn am liebsten stehlen.
Ich muss wachsam sein. Meine
Antennen sind immer ausgefahren.
# Forever you and me ...
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Hier an der ecuadorianischen
Pazifikküste lebt er,
der offenbar
so begehrte Schweizer Tom,
zusammen mit Angie
und Angies Tochter Carlita.
Dich hat es ans Meer gezogen.
War es ein Ziel,
eines Tages am Meer zu leben?
Ich bin nicht jeden Tag im Meer,
aber es ist beruhigend, zu wissen,
dass es gleich hier ist.
Das Geräusch des Meeres
und die Wellen faszinieren mich.
Komm, wir helfen ihnen,
das Boot reinzubringen.
Du, aber ... Das ist ...
Jungs, kommt her,
wir brauchen eure Muckis.
Okay. Un, dos, tres.
Tipptopp.
Es gibt diese Bootstosser,
die allen helfen.
Am Schluss bekommen alle
ein paar Fische gratis.
Die, die gar kein Geld haben ...
- Schau, deine Frau ist am Handeln.
Ich kaufe Crevetten
für ein feines Essen.
Oh, der lebt ja noch.
Ui, está vivo todavía.
Die sind schon tot, oder? Sí?
Muerte. Oh. Nein! Oh my goodness.
Ach.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Ui, aber jetzt gibt es etwas viel.
Was kosten die?
- 10 ¤.
10 ¤? Ya.
Ya falta un poquito.
- Da, bitte.
Hättest du diesen Preis
auch erreicht, Tom?
Ich hätte gar nicht angefangen.
Es war eine Freude,
mit Ihnen zu geschäften.
Gracias.
* Fröhliche, rhythmische Musik *
Direkt am Meer führen Angie und Tom
ein Hotel mit 15 Zimmern.
Folgen Sie mir bitte.
- Was kostet die Nacht?
25 ¤.
Das ist das letzte freie Zimmer.
Statt Vermögen
von reichen Kunden zu verwalten,
hat der ehemalige Banker
sein eigenes Geld genommen
und in dieses Hotel investiert.
* Hupen *
Guten Tag.- Morgen.
- Jetzt kommt der lechero.
1 l, bitte.
Danke und einen schönen Tag.
- Gleichfalls.
Das sind Dinge,
die mich an meine Kindheit erinnern.
Ich ging mit dem Kessel
in den Milchladen
und holte
die frische Milch vom Bauer.
Dann komme ich hierhin und denke,
es ist wie in meiner Kindheit.
Für alles, was ich zum Leben
brauche, kommt einer vorbei.
Home Delivery - das findet hier
schon seit Jahren statt.
Dass Tom alleine arbeitet,
ist selten.
Angie war vor einer Woche
5 Std. beim Coiffeur
und liess ihre Haare strecken.
Jetzt locken sie sich schon wieder.
Sie hat reklamiert.
Sie musste früh am Morgen gehen,
um es noch mal zu machen.
Darum bin ich alleine.
Wir haben
keine klassische Rollenaufteilung.
Derjenige,
der die Arbeit sieht, macht sie.
* Fröhliche, rhythmische Musik *
Guten Morgen, Chef.
- Was hast du heute für mich?
Corviche und gato encerrado.
Alles frisch frittiert.
Gib mir von beidem zwei.
Achtung, sehr heiss.
Danke, pass auf dich auf.
- Du aber auch.- Gracias.
Einer der Dorfalkoholiker, der aber
wenigstens auf legalem Weg versucht,
sein Geld zu verdienen.
Angie sagt,
ich zahle viel zu viel dafür.
Aber ich sage ...
Er hängt wenigstens nicht rum,
pöbelt die Leute an
und macht die hohle Hand.
Wenn er etwas hat, macht er etwas.
Darum kaufe ich immer etwas bei ihm.
* Hupen *
Der Coiffeur
ist im Zentrum des Dorfes Canoa.
Seit über 1 Std.
sitzt Angie schon hier.
Auch wenn es Tom nicht gefällt:
Am Wochenende
will ich mich zurechtmachen.
Alle Männer wollen eine heraus-
geputzte und doch schlichte Frau.
Ausserdem soll Tom
nicht anderen Frauen nachschauen.
Wenn ihn eine anschmachtet,
oh, dann aber reagiere ich.
Muss man, oder?
Sicher doch.
Oft ist es so: Wenn die Frauen
einen Ausländer sehen,
respektieren sie nicht,
dass er schon vergeben ist.
Dann markiere ich elegant, dass er
mir gehört, küsse und umarme ihn.
Das heisst für mich,
mein Revier abstecken.
Die Haare sitzen,
das Wochenende kann kommen.
* Gemütliche Musik *
(Bewundernd) Hola.
Das bleibt jetzt so?
- Wir werden sehen.
* Gemütliche Musik *
Perfekt gestylt und bereit, sich
jeder Herausforderung zu stellen,
geht die Patchworkfamilie
in den Ausgang.
Der Samstagabend ist ihnen heilig.
Der gehört nur ihnen drei.
Vor vielen Jahren
lernten sich die beiden
auf einer Datingplattform kennen.
Lange führten sie eine Fernbeziehung.
Seit drei Jahren leben sie
endlich zusammen als Familie.
Nein. Jetzt hat es geändert.
Er kommt etwas später.
Es geht noch etwa 18 Min.
* Sie seufzt. *
Für Andrea
ist heute der grosse Moment.
Schluss mit der Fernbeziehung.
Pedro, ihre Liebe aus Venezuela,
kommt an.
Und endlich darf er auch bleiben.
Bist du auch etwas nervös?
Ich muss eigentlich nicht nervös
sein.- Müsste ich auch nicht.
Für diesen wichtigen Tag
ist auch ihre Grossmutter
zum Flughafen gekommen.
Damit er sieht, dass er
in der Familie willkommen ist.
Ich habe einen warmen Schal für ihn,
damit er etwas um den Hals hat.
Ab jetzt
sind andere Kleider gefragt.
Feinster Kaschmir,
selbstverständlich.
Das bekommt er für den Hals,
damit ihm gleich warm ist
hier in der Schweiz.
Wir sind schon
bei der Ankunft 1, ja.
* Erwartungsfrohe Musik *
Hoi.
- Hoi.
Everything okay?
- Yeah.
Alles gut?
- Alles gut.
Thank you so much.
- Happy to see you.
Ich kann's kaum glauben.
Ist das alles?
Ja.
- Okay. Das genügt auch.
Ich habe Hunger.
Nach einem
schier endlosen Papierkrieg
hat Pedro endlich
das Hochzeitsvisum bekommen.
Willkommen daheim.
Schuhe ausziehen, ich habe geputzt.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
I'm tired but I ...
- Dinner.
Soll ich etwas kochen?
Oh, nice.
Und wo sind die Essiggurken?
Es klingt komisch, aber
wir müssen uns erst daran gewöhnen,
täglich zusammen zu sein.
- Yeah, of course.
Viele Veränderungen.
Aber gute Veränderungen.
Good changes. Of course.
Und du bekommst nun gutes Essen,
du Glückspilz.
Yes. Cheers.
* Fröhliche Musik *
What if we make toast ...
Wenn meine Arbeit
es verlangen würde,
in die Schweiz zurückzukehren,
würden wir das genau anschauen.
Ich denke, du könntest es dir
grundsätzlich vorstellen,
in der Schweiz zu leben.
Es gibt viele Dinge, die du magst.
Auch vieles, das du nicht magst.
Aber das ist hier in China genauso.
Ja. Ich bin jemand, der sich schnell
an einem neuen Ort zurechtfindet.
* Heitere Klänge *
Auch Mathias
musste sich neu zurechtfinden,
als er vor sieben Jahren
aus der Ostschweiz nach China kam.
Richtig heimisch fühlt er sich erst,
seit er Sharon gefunden
und mit ihr
den kleinen Jonathan bekommen hat.
Ja. Willst du schlafen?
How do you say "suan sai" in german?
- Suan sai?
Sharons Mutter Bi Yan Qiu
lebt bei ihnen in der Wohnung,
seit Sharon schwanger geworden ist.
Sie unterstützt die Familie
wo sie kann.
Tausende Kilometer weit weg gibt es
noch eine andere Mama: Elisabeth.
* Klingelton *
Mami?
- Hoi!- Hoi, hoi.
How are you? Are you at work?
Du bist bei der Arbeit, nicht?
- Yes. Und ihr?
Bist du zu Hause?
- Ja, ich bin zu Hause.
Jonathan schläft gerade.
Ich zeige ihn dir.
Siehst du ihn?
- Meine Güte.
Das ist das letzte Mal,
dass er hier schläft,
bevor er in sein eigenes Bett geht.
Am Wochenende schlafe ich mit ihm
im selben Zimmer.
Unter der Woche sie.
Ich bin extrem dankbar, zu sehen,
dass es euch so gut geht
und ihr
einen solchen Sonnenschein habt.
Aber ich bin auch oft traurig.
Ja.
Sharon, die Mama,
du und Jonathan -
das ist extrem schwierig.
Sharon würde auch gerne
wieder mal in die Schweiz kommen.
Ich würde euch gerne knuddeln
und so.
Ja.
- Ja.
Tschüss.
- Bye.
Das ist recht hart.
* Jonathan weint. *
Jonathan.
Hey.
Wegen der riesigen Distanz ...
Das nächste Mal
kannst du Oma Hallo sagen.
... pflegen sie die Verbindung
in die Schweiz besonders sorgfältig.
Das ist ein Weihnachtsgeschenk
für deinen Götti.
Er ist im richtigen Alter. Die Füsse
haben die geeignete Grösse.
Nein.
Das machst du für deinen Götti
und deine Oma. Hey.
Hast du gesehen,
wie er den Zeh hochgezogen hat?
So: "Ich mache nicht mit."
- That's cool.
Gut gemacht.
So unterschiedlich Sharons
und Mathias' Herkunft sein mag,
beide haben
einen starken Familiensinn.
Ihnen war von Anfang an klar, dass
sie auch selbst eine gründen wollen.
Wir haben es lange geplant
und versucht,
ein Baby zu haben.
Nach einigen Jahren
hat es dann geklappt.
Wir sind sehr stolz auf ihn.
Wir überlegen uns auch,
die Familie noch zu vergrössern.
Vielleicht noch nicht sofort.
Es ist noch zu früh.
Aber wir haben definitiv noch vieles
vor. Familie ist mir sehr wichtig.
Alles ist in Gottes Händen.
Man kann das nicht richtig planen.
Ja, aber es wäre mein Wunsch.
Ja, dass er einen Bruder
oder eine Schwester bekäme.
Hm, Jonathan?
Götti, das ist für dich.
* Sie spricht unverständlich. *
In einem Jahr
möchte ich Deutsch sprechen können.
\Ja, ja.
Einen Job haben.
Und sie wäre vielleicht schwanger.
But I don't know.
Endlich
einen gemeinsamen Alltag haben.
Aber ohne Trauschein
können Andrea und Pedro
weder in Venezuela,
noch in der Schweiz zusammenleben.
Darum soll ihre Liebe offiziell
werden. In einer Woche heiraten sie.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi miteinander.- Grüezi.
Wie kann ich behilflich sein?
Wir heiraten.
Wir haben aber keine Ringe.
Wir wollten schauen,
ob es Anhänger für Ketten gibt -
eine Alternative.
Vielleicht etwas Preiswerteres.
Darf es beides sein? Auch ein Ring?
Wollen wir auch Ringe anschauen?
- Ja.
Das sind unsere Freundschaftsringe.
Die kann man auch
als Trauringe nehmen.
Die gibt es aus Edelstahl oder
Silber.- Die preiswertere Variante.
Genau.
Für Andrea darf es
etwas Unkonventionelles sein.
Am wichtigsten ist aber der Preis.
Noch verdient Marketing-Fachfrau
Andrea das Geld für beide.
Hast du verstanden?
It's just ... well ...
Das sind die preiswerteren Ringe.
Wir haben auch noch überlegt ...
We didn't really check that.
Buchstaben als Anhänger.
- Das geht auch.
Die sind
in Originalgrösse abgebildet.
Sie sind so klein oder gross
wie hier drauf.
In Gelbgold oder Weissgold.
Eigentlich wolltest du keine Ringe.
Und jetzt doch.
Warum hast du die Meinung geändert?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Schwierig zu sagen.
Vielleicht fühlt es sich einfach
richtiger an mit Ehering.
Zu gross?
- A little bit.
Glänzt er nicht zu stark?
Nein, mir gefällt er.
- Okay.
Wir müssen uns entscheiden.
Ich glaube,
er ist eher bei den Ringen.
Wir können den Ring auch ...
- ... um den Hals tragen.
Den ersten Kompromiss im neuen Leben
haben sie erfolgreich gefunden.
I put it on you.
* Gemütlich-fröhliche Musik *
Nehmen wir beides?
I think so, yeah. I like it.
Ja?
- Ja.
Okay.
Von jetzt an musst du einfach
zu allem Ja sagen.
Eines Morgens, wir hatten das Hotel
gerade übernommen,
kamen um 5 Uhr in der Früh Gäste.
Die wollten sofort ein Zimmer haben.
Tom wurde richtig wütend.
Ich sagte zu ihm: "Beruhige dich."
"Wenn du dich
nicht sofort beruhigst, gehe ich."
Denn so läuft das hier nicht.
Man muss ruhig
und liebenswürdig sein.
Du darfst nicht ausflippen.
Ich musste lernen,
Dinge zu akzeptieren.
Sich aufzuregen bringt nichts.
* Schnelle Salsamusik *
Zweimal pro Monat
fahren die drei in die Stadt Manta
zu Angies Familie -
etwa 100 km entfernt.
Ein Leben lang habe ich
mit meiner Familie zusammengelebt.
In unmittelbarer Nähe
leben meine Cousinen, Tanten, Onkel,
meine Geschwister - einfach alle.
Ich habe ihr von Anfang an gesagt:
"Wenn ich in Ecuador lebe, werden
wir nicht bei deinen Eltern leben."
Alle Türen sind offen. Jeder kommt
rein. Es gibt keine Privatsphäre.
Angie ist in einfachen Verhältnissen
aufgewachsen.
Ihre Eltern sind vom Land in die
Stadt gezogen, haben viel gearbeitet
und konnten sich dann
in einer ruhigen Gegend von Manta
ein kleines Haus leisten.
Bis vor drei Jahren
hat Angie mit Carlita hier gelebt.
* Fröhliche, rhythmische Musik *
Hallo, wie geht's?
Hola, cómo estás?
Hola.
Angie hat fünf Geschwister.
Zwei ihrer Brüder haben eine Be-
hinderung und wohnen bei den Eltern.
Don Jorge, guten Tag.
Wie ist es euch ergangen?
- Sehr gut. Und dir?
Gut.
Die Seele der Familie ist Olga,
die Mutter von Angie.
Sie ist fast blind.
Olga hat viel
auf die kleine Carlita aufgepasst,
als Angie noch auf der
Gemeindeverwaltung gearbeitet hat.
Yo ya sabía que iba a ser para Tom.
Der Vater Don Jorge
ist der ruhige Pol der Familie.
Es ist schon fast eine Tradition,
dass es Schweinskopf zu essen gibt,
wenn Tom kommt.
Schweinskopf ist günstig
und eine Delikatesse -
zumindest für Angies Familie.
Als ich es das erste Mal gesehen
habe, war ich nicht so sicher.
Ich esse nicht so oft
Schweinefleisch.
Aber ich möchte das Gesicht
meiner Schwiegermutter gegenüber
nicht verlieren.
Ich beisse in den sauren Apfel
und esse einige Happen.
Und ich sollte dann auch sagen,
dass es gut ist.
Für Tom gibt es noch eine
Gnadenfrist: Zuerst gibt es Kaffee.
Guten Appetit.
Die Gunst der Schwiegermutter
zu gewinnen, war wichtig für Tom.
Es war für mich schon ein Schlag.
Als er mich fragte,
ob er Angie mitnehmen dürfe,
sagte ich zu ihm: "Du hast sie mir
doch schon lange weggenommen."
Für meine Tochter ist er gut.
Für mich wäre er nichts.
Vor Jahren konnte sich Angie
im hinteren Teil des Grundstücks
ein eigenes Haus bauen.
Das ist mein Haus.
Eine Wohnküche mit Bad und Dusche
und oben zwei Zimmer.
Ich habe beim Bau mitgeholfen.
Ich bin die Leiter rauf und runter,
habe Zement gerührt, gemalt.
Und doch, das Haus hat mich
meine ganzen Ersparnisse gekostet.
Als später wegen des Erdbebens
der obere Stock wieder zusammenfiel,
half mir Tom, diesen neu aufzubauen.
Als alleinerziehende Mutter
war sie froh,
dass sie gleich neben ihrer Familie
wohnen konnte.
Hier habe ich so viele Erinnerungen.
Und so viel Arbeit.
Der leibliche Vater von Carlita
hat nie Verantwortung übernommen.
Angie war ganz auf die Hilfe
ihrer Familie angewiesen.
In den schlimmsten Momenten meines
Lebens haben sie mir immer geholfen.
Mein Bruder ...
Alle sind mir beigestanden.
Meine Mutter auch.
Das war unser Zimmer,
als Tom hierhergekommen ist.
Zurück in die Gegenwart.
Hier geht's zur Sache.
Wenn er noch blutig wäre,
würde ich ohnmächtig werden.
Ja, das weiss ich doch.
Und wenn ich ein Huhn schlachte,
gefällt ihm das gar nicht.
Ich denke, das macht ihm halt Angst.
Wir Frauen sind härter im Nehmen.
Stimmt doch.
Das sehe ich bei uns zu Hause.
Mein Ehemann sagt zu allem Nein.
Und ich sage dann erst recht Ja.
So läuft der Hase.
Olga ist nicht nur die Seele, sondern
auch klar die Chefin der Familie.
Achtung, Mama.
Angie
hat ihre Stärke nicht gestohlen.
Ihre Mutter hat sie ihr vorgelebt.
Wo ist die Zunge?
Es como la tuya.
Das Gefühl, das sie mir gibt ...
Ich glaube, die Mutter und der Vater
von Angie mögen mich.
V.a. die Mutter.
Es ist beruhigend,
dass ich hierherkommen kann.
Dass sie nicht denken:
"Oh, jetzt kommt der schon wieder."
Das ist schön.
Und das Hirn?
Wir lassen es da, wo es ist.
Nach 3 Std. in der Pfanne
ist der Kopf butterweich geschmort.
Dazu gibt es Yucca-Wurzel und Reis.
Für mich eine kleine Portion.
Guten Appetit.
(Kleines Mädchen) Buen provecho.
- (Alle) Gracias.
No pollito.
Nein, nicht Reis mit Poulet.
Reis mit Schwein.
Ella dice: "Me gusta arroz pollito."
Arroz con cerdito.
* Alle lachen. *
Mir schmeckt es.
Aber ich könnte nicht sagen, dass
ich dafür sehr weit gehen würde.
Meine Lieblingsspeise ist es nicht.
Es war wieder sehr schön bei euch.
Danke.
Mein Land ist chaotisch.
Hier ist es wirklich schön.
Es ist toll.
Really amazing for me.
I really like it.
Ob Venezuela oder die Schweiz -
wenn das Hochzeitsfieber grassiert,
wird es überall hektisch.
Womit beginnen wir?
(Frau) Habt ihr nur einen Kamm?
- So einen, ja.
Das brauche ich nie. Er hat einen.
Ich weiss nicht, wo der ist.
Hm ...
Es kann nicht sein,
dass er ihn mitgenommen hat.
Und er ist nicht da.
Es sollte schon lange da sein.
Eine Freundin mit Flair für Frisuren
übernimmt an diesem wichtigen Tag
die Rolle der Coiffeuse.
Die Frage ist, ob du zuerst
die Zöpfchen machen kannst.
Mein Coiffeuse hat gesagt,
sie würde diese Haare wegnehmen.
Letztes Mal sah es so aus.
So.
- Ja, genau.
Wann kommt er denn?
- Sein Termin war von 9 bis 10 Uhr.
So blöd.
Er soll jetzt kommen.
* Tür *
Hallo?
- Hallo.
Hallo!
Hallo.
Du bist spät dran.
Haben sie dich verunstaltet?
Hello.
Lass mich sehen.
- Looking good.
Bist du zufrieden?
Ja, es ist okay.
- But it's good.
Leider hatte die Frau
keine grosse Erfahrung mit Bärten.
Ich musste ihr alles erklären.
Ich musste mich selbst frisieren.
Ich war ein wenig irritiert.
Aber was soll's?
Heute ist der grosse Tag.
Nichts kann mir die Freude nehmen.
Wir haben die Bürste gesucht.
Ja, wo ist die?
Die dünne schwarze.
The hair brush. The thin one.
- Yeah, yeah.
Where is it?
- Im Büro.
Im Büro?
Da habe ich gesucht. Umsonst.
Okay.
- Where was ist?
In the office.
Die Zeit wird immer knapper.
In 2 Std.
muss auch das Hochzeitskleid sitzen.
Dann beginnt die Trauung.
Wir sind an einem Punkt,
an dem wir wieder neu beginnen -
für das letzte Lebensdrittel.
Ein total neues Abenteuer.
Vielleicht für ihn mehr
als für mich.
Ich hatte mein Abenteuer.
* Ruhige Country-Klänge *
There you are. There you go.
Wegen der Liebe ist Brigitte
Jay nach Montana in die USA gefolgt.
Irgendwann aber wurde das Heimweh
nach ihren Töchtern so stark,
dass sie zurückgehen musste.
Oh yes. Sit.
Jay war sofort klar, dass es jetzt
an ihm ist, die Heimat zu verlassen.
Schliesslich gehören sie zusammen.
Und das, obwohl er noch nie
ausserhalb der USA gelebt hat.
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
So, Mädels. Habt ihr Eier gelegt?
Da gibt es keine.
- Okay. Sie muss es noch lernen.
Oh, da gibt es drei.
- Three? Oh, cool.
Okay. Got them. Hey girls.
So, wie geht es euch?
Yes.
Als ich
etwa acht oder neun Jahre alt war,
hatte ich statt einen Hund Hühner.
Als Erwachsener im Reservat hatte
ich während gut 15 Jahren Hühner.
Wir haben immer dafür gebetet,
dass wir hier Hühner, Hund, Garten,
einen eigenen Ort haben werden.
Das alles haben wir nun.
Wo immer wir hingehen,
wir bringen es zum Laufen.
Die beiden
sind durch schwere Zeiten gegangen.
Beide sind an Krebs erkrankt.
Vor fünf Monaten haben sie Jay
in den Staaten einen Tumor entfernt.
Vor Kurzem
hatte er die Nachuntersuchung.
Ich habe gute Neuigkeiten:
Ich muss keine Chemo machen.
Sie fanden jedoch einen Knoten,
den wollen sie genauer untersuchen.
Ich hoffe,
dass ich bald krebsfrei bin,
wie meine wunderbare Frau.
Ja, ich bin mega froh.
Ihr Krebs hat mich viel mehr
beunruhigt als meiner.
Ich will sie nicht verlieren,
sie ist mein Leben.
Die beiden sind dem Big Creator,
dem grossen Schöpfer, dankbar.
Kommt zu uns, ihr Ahnen.
Hört unsere Gebete.
Schöpfer, wir danken dir
für all die guten Dinge,
die du uns gegeben hast:
ein Heim, das Essen.
Gute Freunde.
Freunde, meine Frau, meinen Hund.
Der mutige schwarze Adler
hat gesprochen. Thank you.
Oh.
Die weise Bärin von weit her
hat gesprochen.
Brigitte und Jay
kosten das Leben aus,
mit all seinen Möglichkeiten.
Es ist so schön hier,
ich freue mich so.
* Leises Plätschern,
ein Hahn kräht. *
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass wir dort ein Tipi aufstellen.
Auch Jay hat einen Plan.
Er möchte ein Buch schreiben.
Ich habe einen Abschluss
als sog. Medizinmann.
In meinem Buch
möchte ich eine Verbindung schaffen
zwischen den Native Americans
und der westlichen Welt.
Damit wir uns alle
besser verstehen können.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmelodie *
There's even a bench,
if you need to rest.
ALright, sit down, I take a picture.
Schau dich an, meine Königin.
My queen.
You're too cool.
There you go.
Ich bin happy und froh,
dass wir hier sind.
Wir haben hier
eine gewisse Sicherheit, Freunde ...
... Familie, es ist gut.
Meine einzige Erwartung an sie ist,
mit ihr zusammen sein zu können.
Und zwar in diesem, dem nächsten
und übernächsten Leben.
Der Schöpfer
hätte sie nicht zum Sterben,
sondern zum Leben
in die Schweiz gebracht.
Davon sind beide überzeugt.
Mit dieser Zuversicht
schauen sie in die Zukunft.
It says: "Schau ins Tal",
"Look into the valley".
Well, we will.
Good?
Juhu!
This is gorgeous.
(Flüsternd) Look a this.
Es ist traurig,
dass meine Eltern
nicht dabei sein können.
Ich habe Pedro einfach
irgendwo stehen lassen, oh nein.
Für Pedros Eltern
war es in Venezuela unmöglich,
innert nützlicher Frist
einen gültigen Pass für die Einreise
in die Schweiz zu bekommen.
(Frau) Grüezi.
Entschuldige, ich habe dich
schon verlassen. Ups.- Ups.
* Leises Stimmengewirr *
Liebes Brautpaar,
liebe Trauzeugen, liebe Gäste.
Mit dem heutigen Tag beginnt für sie
ein neuer Lebensabschnitt.
Sie haben sich entschlossen,
miteinander die Ehe einzugehen
und ihren weiteren Lebensweg von
nun an als Eheleute zu beschreiten.
Sie verpflichten sich gegenseitig,
das Wohl der Gemeinschaft in ein-
trächtigem Zusammenwirken zu wahren
und für die Kinder
gemeinsam zu sorgen.
Sie schulden einander
Treue und Beistand.
Die restlichen Regeln
können sie selber machen.
Er hat alles verstanden.
Wichtig ist,
dass er das Ja-Wort versteht.
Möchten Sie, Frau Andrea Götz,
mit Herrn Pedro Dugarte Sanchez
die Ehe eingehen,
dann antworten Sie mit Ja.
Ja.
Und möchten Sie,
Herr Pedro Dugarte Sanchez,
mit Frau Andrea Götz die Ehe
eingehen, dann antworten Sie mit Ja.
Ja.
Da Sie beide meine Frage
mit "Ja" beantwortet haben,
ist Ihre Ehe durch Ihre gemeinsame
Zustimmung geschlossen.
Ich würde sagen,
das ist einen Applaus wert.
* Romantische Musik *
Alles Gute.
Pedro ist nicht nur
in Andreas Herzen,
auch ihre Familie
nimmt ihn mit offenen Armen auf.
Bienvenido.
Herzlich willkommen
in unserer Familie.
Danke, Papa.
- Das ist jetzt etwas emotional.
Eins, zwei, drei!
* Kameraklicken *
(Frau) Schön.
* Sanfte Streicher-
und Klavierklänge *
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Ich weiss nicht, ob eine Hochzeit
wirklich ein Liebesbeweis ist -
man sagt es zwar, aber ...
Aus meiner Sicht
ist es ein grösserer Beweis,
wenn ich ihr jeden Tag
meine Liebe bestätige.
Sie kommt manchmal und sagt:
"Hast du heute nicht vergessen,
mir etwas zu sagen?"
Dann sage ich:
"Nein, ich habe es dir
heute Morgen schon gesagt."
Aber ich sage es dir noch mal:
Te amo.
* Entspannte Gitarrenmusik *
Tom hat sich in Ecuador
gut eingelebt.
Ein paar Dinge hat er aber
aus der Schweiz mitgebracht.
Darunter die Freude an Velotouren,
die man in Canoa nicht so kennt.
* Schlussakkorde *
Das reicht wohl noch nicht, es muss
noch etwas runter.- Meinst du?
Bist du eine gewiefte Velofahrerin?
In der Schweiz
kann jeder Velofahren.
Das ist ein Geheimnis:
Ich fahre nicht gerne Velo.
Gehen wir? Soll ich zuerst?
Ich habe dich schon ausgelacht
wegen deinem ...
Das ersetzt meinen Easy Rider
von zu Hause.
Wir haben zu Hause
ein altes Motorrad.
Eine alte Harley.
* Entspannte Gitarrenmusik *
Wir machen eine Velotour ins Inland.
Nos extraña ver Carla en bicicleta.
Angie und Carlita
sind tapfer mit dabei.
Schau, sie lachen und denken: "Was
kommen da für welche mit dem Velo?"
Hola, buenas tardes.
Wir sind unterwegs
zu einer Cervecería,
einer ecuadorianischen Bierbrauerei.
Buenas tardes.
- Hola, buenas tardes.
Kommt ihr vorwärts?
- (Mann) Ja, ja.
Ist es noch weit?
Wir sind ... fast dort.
Deine Tochter ist schon muy cansada.
* Vögel zwitschern,
schnelle Salsaklänge *
Hola.
- Hola.
Mein Güte, was für ein Weg!
Ein richtiges Abenteuer.
Komm zu mir!
Wir sollten das öfter machen,
wir sind das dritte Mal ...
Hoy es la tercera vez en bici, no?
Das dritte Mal.
* Entspannte Salsaklänge *
Tom und Angie:
Die beiden tragen Verantwortung
für Carlita, führen ein Hotel
arbeiten jeden Tag, trotzdem wirken
sie immer noch frisch verliebt.
Jetzt kommt unser Bier.
- Ui.
Gracias.
Oh, la, la.
Salud.
(Alle) Salud.
Die beiden leben in
einer eingetragenen Partnerschaft.
Trotz aller Romantik
haben sie nicht geheiratet.
Wollen sie das
irgendwann noch nachholen?
Eine Hochzeit in Weiss
war nie ein Traum von mir.
Wirklich nicht?
- Nein.
Okay.
Meiner aber schon.
Nicht verheiratet zu sein,
raubt mir nicht den Schlaf.
Ich bin glücklich
in meiner Situation.
Ich bin mit meiner Carlita, ich bin
mit ihm, dem Mann, den ich liebe.
Ich habe eine tolle Arbeit -
was will ich mehr?
Sie ist die Frau meines Lebens.
Wenn sie mich nicht rauswirft,
dann bleiben wir zusammen.
Ich liebe und schätze ihn sehr.
Ich weiss,
er wird mich nie im Stich lassen.
Oh, das ist fast zu viel mich.
Yo te amo mucho.
Du bist ein grosses Geschenk
für mich.
Ich liebe dich sehr,
mein schöner Schweizer.
Ya, dejen de estar así.
* Angie lacht. *
* Verträumte Gitarrenklänge *
Also, wenn man vor Glück weinen kann,
ist etwas vom Schönsten,
das einem passieren kann.
Claro, es que amo a mi amor mucho.
Te amo.
Ven, mi amor, dame otro abrazo.
Vamos. Vamos?
- Ja.
Die Liebe nimmt nicht immer
den einfachsten Weg.
Umso schöner, wenn Menschen ihn
trotzdem gemeinsam meistern.
Wenn dich die Liebe
auch an einen Ort verschlagen hat,
den du nicht für möglich gehalten
hättest, dann melde dich bei uns.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
D. Zacheo, M. Riedi,
M. Hoss - 2022